giving you 30 seconds to decide
hey guys it's the holidays and that
means i'm giving a gift to jasmine i
know it's torture for her but it's
really a gift to myself if you're just
joining us today we take a recipe we put
it into google translate we go from
english to europe to bengali to spanish
and many many many many more until we
bring it back to english and we get this
hilariously translated recipe i'm gonna
give this to jasmine and we'll see if
she can make it through another one
let's do it i'm scared again happy
holidays happy holidays katie this is my
gift to you oh i'm so excited also just
an excuse to spend time together oh
absolutely i would dream of nothing more
are you ready for those recipes we know
this how i feel about this all the time
fun in a glass sounds like us
one gift you have is well it's not a
gift it's really a curse you only get
two hints today we're gonna have fun the
hint you will get free is that it's
holiday related oh what do you mean that
is holiday really i don't think it's
going to help you very much where's
kelly i need kelly kelly can't be here
today i know she's off on her holidays
so i miss her let's get started i also
have a few more questions katie um
yep we're doing it you ready
step one put one cup milk on fire cook
and cook
see now i'm scared because last time i
messed up on step number one it impacted
the rest of it so is it milk i don't
know i don't know
milk water
yogurt why don't you see what's out
there maybe we didn't even put these
things you're messing with me once i
look at that my whole brain oh turns
heavy whipping cream could definitely be
an option milk i'm between these two
milk and heavy whipping cream
no no no no none of this colluding i'll
venmo you if you give me a hint right
now then moe bed
this is mean what if i'm being nice it's
the holidays what if i'm being mean it's
the whole one
i will go with milk because i trust
katie she's such a good friend of mine
we're gonna add one cup of milk and set
it on fire i assume cook and cook means
bring to a boil or
simmer
step number two the problem is there
sure is add a half glass of butter and
half glass of sugar the results are
described below
i can't read below half glass of butter
half stick okay here's some butter cool
i'm gonna use this so what do you think
that is
a butter cutter this is not strong
enough to cut the butter half glass half
cup of melted butter we are going to add
half a cup of butter half cup of sugar
brown sugar granulated sugar powdered
sugar i think it's half cup of sugar i'm
adding half a cup of sugar
into the saucepan and then i'm just
gonna give this a mix the results are
described below maybe take off heat
let's remove it from heat now that
everything is melted step number three
pour the mixture into a large bowl wake
up and mix add the eggs and mix with the
cement cement large bowl we got a large
bowl over here
so i guess i'm gonna pour the mixture
into a large bowl wake up
oh is it chill you know like when you're
sleeping and you get cold water hit on
your face you wake up
that silence was so loud add the egg and
mix with the cement how many add the
eggs add the eggs full egg egg whites
egg yolks eggs full eggs whole eggs do
you want a hint you know what i think
this is important because eggs can be
binders they're important for flavor and
coloring so yes let's use a hint
sometimes letters just appear to make
something plural
oh
okay so one egg that was the best hint
okay so i'm going to add one egg
add the eggs and mix with the cement
whisk because whisk is hard like cement
i wish christmas music was plain right
now alexa play christmas music on
spotify
and then add snow
and maybe a snowman dancing
and rudolph
the whisk is cement because it's hard
like cement when you're up here
anything's possible all right next step
step number four add four cups flour one
tablespoon yeast half teaspoon salt and
caramelize
boil the flour in five to seven minutes
until light and fluffy i think i need a
stand mixer add four cups of flour in
here okay i feel like we're gonna make
some sort of dough let me just bring the
stand mixer over i don't know if i'm
doing this right but you know what fun
in a glass the caramel thing is really
messing with me i do think boil
could be
baked my gut says mix so i'm gonna do
the dry ingredients first here and then
i'll add this in later all right we're
gonna do four cups of flour okay one
tablespoon of yeast half teaspoon salt i
believe that now i think i did it wrong
because it's in the same step but you
don't put salt with yeast together so
i'm gonna add it to my egg mixture and
caramel no caramel cardamom i don't
think it's caramel because i've never
done something like that before but i do
think it could be cardamom i think maybe
cardamom because it sounds kind of like
caramel but how much a pinch half
teaspoon that's a lot no
boil the flour in five to seven minutes
until light and fluffy oh
knead the dough for five to seven
minutes i've taken out the stand mixer i
put a dough hook attachment on there
we're just going to mix this until it's
well combined and i think i'm going to
take it out and knead it myself just
going to lightly flour my surface and
then i'm going to finish kneading this
until it's a little softer
all right next step step number five
place flour in a greased pan i sat at
one o'clock so i need to grease my
pan a dutch oven
all right got a dutch oven i think we're
making dutch oven bread
i'm gonna just grease this a little bit
have you made dutch oven bread before no
actually so this will be my first time
yes
all right i think that's good i sat at
one o'clock rest one hour
i'm having the realization that i don't
need to put in a dutch oven to rest for
an hour so i know it's wrong i'm just
gonna leave it one in a glass
have a good nap holiday music break
boy should we get on dance with you
they're gonna not add music to the
editor
alexa
step number six ingredients two
tablespoon melt butter
quarter cup high pam sugar
one tablespoon sugar
what the heck and two teaspoons channel
you know what let's just gather let's
just source the ingredients butter
quarter cup high pam sugar
i do not think it's pam though powdered
sugar i don't know if that's right yet
but let's just bring it out first one
tablespoon sugar two teaspoons channel
which channel channel
uh
channel
cinnamon starts with the c i think i'm
gonna do
cinnamon for channel i'm gonna keep
powdered sugar i'm just going with my
gut here first order of business is to
melt the butter so i have my melted
butter here i'm just gonna add
everything directly into there i'm gonna
add a quarter cup of powdered sugar
watch it be wrong
uh one tablespoon sugar and then two
teaspoons
of chanel now this is what i call fun in
the glass next we open the dough on
paper
and give it a size of 12 by 18. so
formal
let me go get my baby
do i need a baking tray i'm gonna grab a
baking tray paper parchment paper
there's no baking tray so
no problem
we open the dough on paper
i think it's saying we open the dough on
parchment paper i have myself a
measuring stick
lovely i also need a rolling pin let's
flower our surface how are you feeling
honestly i'm so hyped right now i
finally feel better i'm just gonna have
fun with it after all we're making fun
in a class if you don't have fun while
making it we're not making it you know
step number eight spread the flour over
all the flour meal with one cup
yang yu
half cup grapes
and quarter cup almonds oh i found
grapes eat walnuts i have a feeling that
it's walnuts because it's the holidays
and if this is a holiday dish i am used
to seeing bread with cinnamon and nuts
and the nuts are usually walnuts
i'm just gonna look one more time though
golden raisins can we please leave
raisins out of this spread flour over
the flour spread my mixture over
the dough okay spreading this i'm gonna
do until it's even i think that's good
enough kneel with one cup yangyuu
walnuts here is my issue with the
walnuts i feel like they should be
crushed
okay while i crush that what's the next
one half cup grapes i think that's gonna
be almonds i think it's raisins get it
you gotta make it
the way you think i don't want raisins
in my bread i think grapes is raisins so
i'm using golden raisins here i think
that's enough do you think you've gotten
everything right so far yes
quarter cup almonds you know earlier i
saw almond paste do you think that's a
thing i just feel like it would not make
sense to put whole raw almonds i think
it's almond paste let's try a new
ingredient step number nine it's on a
long rack roll the dough into a ring tie
it up and put it down apply the ring
to your skin oh roll and then roll and
then cover with saran wrap roll the
dough into a ring so i think now it's
like this
wait tie it up i saw a wire earlier
honestly why don't i let you read the
next step katie's letting me read the
next step which is
crazy step number 10 use a wire to cut
two-thirds of the side of the loop at a
distance of two inches turn each piece
forward that did not help
how might would you like a hint i would
like to use my hint okay it's gonna be
from emo dearest memo might you give me
the best hint ever well my hint is
the wire does not belong in the kitchen
[Laughter]
cut two thirds of the side of the
oh oh oh oh i'm not sure if this is
but i want to cut around it and twist it
now i am going to turn each piece
forward and i'm going to have the loop
facing up well if anything i love the
new creations we come up with here on
this show so fun in a glass
she's beauty what's her name grace he is
grace
[Laughter]
next step step number 11 close the lid
and leave for 30 minutes i'm gonna
transfer this to the dutch oven i did
not think that through i should put it
on paper watch this
i need another cutting board what if you
get another piece of parchment and flip
it over onto that one
one more piece of paper
no problem
yeah
close the lid and leave for 30 minutes
i'm gonna leave this for 30 minutes i
have no idea how i'm feeling but i still
think we're having fun in a glass so
step 12 check the altitude at 375
degrees for 25 minutes check the
altitude is big bake at 375 for 25
minutes yeah
okay so we're gonna let this sit for 30
minutes and then we're going to bake it
at 375 for 25 minutes brb
it's ready
wow it's so cute
step 13 remove the bread from the oven
and put the refrigerator on a low heat
all right there is a cooling rack over
here i think this step means to transfer
the bread onto a cooling rack and let it
cool grace you're beautiful step number
14 make a face mask mix one cup cup of
powder and one and a half tablespoon
milk pour the butter over the cold cake
one cup
cup of powder is one cup of
powdered sugar and one and a half
tablespoons of milk pour the butter whoa
whoa whoa okay so i think what we're
doing is creating a glaze i'll start
with
the one cup of powdered sugar one and a
half tablespoons of milk just gonna mix
that up this is almost combined pour
butter over the cold cake maybe like
drizzle i'm doing it yeah yeah glaze it
how you'd want to glaze it you wouldn't
be able to see the bread anymore
final step
step number 15 if desired combine with
thai if desired top with powdered sugar
if desired topped with
maraschino cherries
oh is this cinnamon
thai maraschino cherries you tie it with
your tongue the stems cherry
giving you 30 seconds to decide
i'll do one cherry
yeah
just one just one just one no more i
just don't think it belongs so just what
fun in a glass
you feel good i mean she's cute i like
her so i feel good are you ready to see
the real one i'm ready to see her and
i'm ready to eat it okay are you ready
i'm ready bring her in okay open your
eyes
oh my gosh
the ring was a real ring
this is really cute mine looks like it
could go in the center of this this
looks like a wreath with ornaments i
should have known better what is this
supposed to be so it's called a swedish
tea ring kelly chose the recipe before
she left because she couldn't be here
thank you kelly i can't get over how
wrong i am but it feels like a remix
i'm really into the fact that i don't
need to cut mine i could just pull it
off so i'm gonna do that
you can't do that
mmm they're yummy very good so good say
nicer thanks i love it cinnamon rolls i
like that it's soft it's fluffy the
cinnamon's nice i like it but i'm really
excited to try british tea ring cheers
there's too many raisins this one
definitely feels a little more complex
and i do like the cherry i should have
had mine with cherry you got a lot right
if your assembly was where you really
went astray but you did a really good
job well this was super fun i enjoyed
every part of this make sure you guys
keep your eyes peeled for the next one
it's gonna be really special really fun
and a little bit different turn on your
notification bell and we will see you
next time happy holidays happy holidays
how about the
window with a meal
you